so was geht hier ist euer max und
herzlich willkommen zur heutigen folge
minecraft nero wieder mit patrick
sprechen wir darüber
wir können wissen sprechen sollte ich
muss nie ich bin ein bisschen etwas
passiert eben morgen dann auf einen
bestimmten kanal eines teilnehmer sehen
aber mehr verrate ich nicht
ärgerlich dass also ich mache mir gerade
mal hier ein bogen hatte das mache ich
immer falsch den bogen in mein traum war
schon wieder zurzeit zack zack da ist
das ist so basic steht den ich einfach
nicht drauf habe irgendwie so ich habe
es einen bogen und 360 weil ich habs
gerade glaubt ein gast hat und man hört
übertrieben wenn du tipps das ist
wahrscheinlich die sprach aktivierung
oder so keine ahnung aber ich habe hier
gerade tatsächlich gast gehört es wäre
natürlich echter schritt wenn hier
direkt einer wäre ja denn wir mussten
also ich muss auch wie gesagt noch kaum
retten
jones ich weiß nicht ob ich das erste
mal mache bekomme ist natürlich mal
wieder gestorben
so können wir den guten und ich muss
noch überzeugt von dem holen ich glaube
das mache ich jetzt schnell weil ich bin
jetzt gerade direkt an portalen da kann
ich mich nächsten folgen ein bisschen
bewegen
und ja also ab in die stadt zurück und
du bist wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht so
gesprächig
am handy oder beschäftigt hier irgendwo
komme geschoben okay kein wunder bei den
ganzen mops hier
wenn ich jetzt auch stärker es stinkt
mir nicht die stärke die stadt nicht so
sehr gut ich lebe und hier wird er
wahrscheinlich seien gefallen sein
nehmt ihr mal an das ist es da und ist
auch der grabstein okidoki ja gut
überlebe ich dass man sich da wieder
hoch schwimme ich weiß nicht ich sehen
weil ich mich erschrocken etwas hat auf
dem server djk ich will nicht riskieren
ich werde nicht riskieren leute ich
werde existieren und es wird nacht oder
besser was du auf mir ist auf mir ist
neben mir es noch mal da die server für
dich komm wir schreiben das aufnimmt
die konnte man dass sie gott ich habe
ein bisschen schiss per drittes wird
gerade nacht und alter macht der schaden
dieser usa wo sie doch mal auf meine
kiss diese lieder eine rüstung die
scheibe kann sie ausleihen
ja ich muss jetzt erstmal warten ich www
eigentlich meine ganze folge darauf
verschwenden
so habe ich im slot freien die habe ich
nicht so etwas nämlich dafür gott kann
ich über garten so gut
und hier hat man klauen wirklich
immerhin eine kiste gleich und wollt ihr
diese gelesene rüstungschef plate vor
habe ich jetzt gerade bekommen von gomez
jedoch und sagen ach gott kontron ist es
mega stress ich gerade
ich muss das irgendwie retten siehst du
den grabstein ich sehe ich habe direkt
vor augen
es ist es irgendwie total buggy hier
gerade okay okay so jetzt aber jetzt
aber leute tut mir leid ich bin gerade
entgegen das ist da komm schon
so zeigt so und es abgebaut ist jetzt
runter das ist der grabstein des
weggeschwommen nein eine das ja wirklich
passiert ist jetzt ganz unten
oh gott ja wohl einfach ich hoffe mal
dass er ist da unten ist ja okay ich
habe ihn auch wie stressig also über
stressig ist jetzt an entlang des
wasserfalls nicht gesetzt habe dass ich
wieder hoch was ist er unter geschwommen
nach ganz unten in die kate wo wir in
der ersten folge waren
wenn ich jetzt sterben ist eine rüstung
ist unbesiegbar sieht man nicht aber das
schon dann ist das die den schaden
reflektiert die seilbahn okay warum
wolltest du kämpfen
nein aber du kannst du bist ganz aus
seien damit nicht somit wissen eine
haushalts- und keine angst sogar noch
ein bisschen zeit gewesen von goma
das kann ich ihm auf jeden fall
zurückgeben ich hoffe dass jetzt nichts
wert weil das wegwerfen so okay aber ich
werde es an nicht mehr eine ganze folge
darauf an wänden leute also tut mir leid
dass hier jetzt nicht alles doch gott
schenkt den grabsteinen setzt den ok
schwimmen da jetzt hoch verdammt noch
mal sechs minuten sind schon drauf
gegangen
heute ist mir leid aber ich hab
natürlich gesagt dass ich komme relativ
man ist ja eigentlich selbstverständlich
schon fünfmal silber und dann wird man
auch ja gerettet werden ja eben absolut
und deshalb habe ich jetzt kann man
natürlich auch meine hilfe zugesagt
es ist noch nichts gekommen dass jetzt
macht ist und ich kann wirklich so
herzlich darauf verzichten dass das die
jetzt nacht wird gerade eben war dass du
alles so dunkel ich weiß nicht ob die
nacht vorbei ist jetzt ich sehe mir fast
so aus als wäre es vorbei das wäre
natürlich eine angemessene belohnung für
meine guten taten hier was wäre
eigentlich kam er schon soweit sagen
wenn ich in der gegnerischen stadt
sterben in grabstein wenn ich jetzt gab
es nicht so eine sonderregel wo ist was
los
der grabstein der grabstein ist nicht da
dessen inventar das nicht auf gesammelt
weil du nicht in keinen platz hat ist
ich hatte natürlich platz also geguckt
ob du den drin hatte sein
ich habe den gesehen da und hat so
bekloppt nicht dass ich gerade wie guck
mal richtig dementer ob das sich nicht
da ist
der ist nicht da war jede slot absolut
nicht da
hendrik kurz zurück man daraus nicht
wieder ganz runter ich weiß ich kann dir
nicht sagen also also zumindest stelle
ich schon mal an gomez ehemaliges grad
die kiste mit seinem alten zeug die
regel mit dem grafschafter richte die
macht über kennst sind halt ein bisschen
stressig wenn man dass man verliert hat
zeit einfachste teilweise
na gut aber dafür hilfen hat dem anderen
das auch wieder aufnehmen kann das finde
ich super gut dass man sich einfach
aussetzen muss dann muss man sich den
graf selber einfach weg spaß machen
ja verdammt alt jetzt einfach mal
wichtiger okay dann hätten wir jetzt wo
wir es noch mal das zeug zu finden von
komme wenn ich das jetzt nicht finde ich
dreh durch und runter runter runter
runter runter meine mama trainiert jetzt
nochmal komplett runter bitte ist das
noch da das ding ich verstehe es halt
einfach nicht wenn ich jetzt nicht da
ist das teil war doch hier verdammt noch
mal
das ist jetzt aber nicht so stark aus
nein nicht nicht so nicht so nicht so
ich wird nicht so schnell ich werde so
nicht zum ersten mal sterben leute
definitiv nicht definitiv nicht okay der
großes verbrannt alter der mit übel
schaden gemacht und später einmal
getroffen mit einem 27 er tritt uns hat
er einfach nicht gejuckt
also hab ich das ding jetzt gerade auf
gesamtem einem inventar oder hatte ich
die ganze zeit drin leute falls ja dann
das wissen mich tötet mich in den
kommentaren wer die ganzen zeit nicht
drin so wie du geredet hat auch was den
eindruck hat dass ich mir sicher war es
dass sie gerade verkackt heute ist mir
einfach nur leid falls das da drin war
und ihr euch gerade einfach dass tom
küster aufgeregt hat
so schlimm ist ein vergleich was ich
gemacht habe reinschauen
erst dann kann immer ein bisschen
schneller schwimmen hier gleich wer
heute noch nach enormer in die hölle
kommen
ich will die hölle kommen seht ihr was
sagt man auch nur bei minecraft nähere
oder generell bei minecraft borst so
stressig der schwimmt so langsam
sprinter dabei klang ja ich das bringen
wir auch nicht wirklich was okay wir
sind gleich oben leute haben wir nur
noch oh gott ist das stressig
das ist weil man doch die zeit wird
verrückt
eigentlich brauche ich mich ja gar nicht
beklagen viele so oft sterben teilweise
die haben einfach nix macht und das geld
gab ihr euch leute die durchgehend
gestorben genau jetzt gerade meine
ersten tod kriege ich habe zu sehr ein
gesteigertes will glaubte kaum komme mal
wieder bekomme ist gerettet
kannst du mal schreiben in dem bock hast
ich gebe ihm noch seine millionen zurück
die waren mit ihren verschiedenen so ich
weiß jetzt nicht geht es mir in mein
haus in dein haus ja okay was ist dann
könnte dieser deal eine rüstung sondern
genetisch so gut wie hält genau so viel
aus wie meine neue ich habe halt diesem
special effekt bei mir okay also die
swine die rüstung dann tue ich mal für
die zeit lang zumindest für damit diese
benutzt benutzte eisen rüstung noch
günstig
ins inventar so kommen erstmal ein
bisschen shit weg hier man verliert so
viel zeit einfach weil das inventar
ungeordnet ist teilweise so und was kann
ich noch weg machen
101 so zeigt ein da rein der rainer
brechtken lern slot für die gas träne
weil das weiß ich das noch schaffen
sollte okay danke schön für die rüstung
zehn von zehn halter stick kein problem
du wirst natürlich auch teil daran haben
wenn ich mich durch eine durch blatt
magic unter anderem teleportieren kann
leute wir kommen überlegen wo wir uns
hin teleportieren ich bin letzte der die
rüstungs klammer ohne spaß
okay ich bin aber jetzt bestens aus wo
das irgend komischer zauberer der stress
will der dieser netter mensch weiß ob er
gut ist welches die kämpfen die gegen
fernkampf okay da ist ein gas- und ehrt
mich getan hat mich fitter cockpit ist
nicht in lahr
ich muss es schaffen dass er über die
moore getrennt
ich muss schaffen dass wir über den
abgrund kommen alter wasser habe ich zum
glück immer ich sagt hey ich will vilbel
dorf tag habe ich ein wilder doch ich
will gas tag habe ich ein gast komm her
bruder kommen nicht raus ist er direkt
tot eigentlich eine anschließe ja wenn
du dich wenn du den zurückgehen
diese attacke zurück reflektiert ist
entdeckt wird ich wähle ich war verdammt
okay er kommt er kommt ja er muss aber
ganz sicher darüber sein sonst lohnt
sich das nicht sonst lohnt sich das
nicht kaum verdammt nochmal herden
penner die fliegen so unkontrolliert
achtet ist auch so gas fliegen ja nicht
nicht du kannst ja nicht abholen
das ist zufall ob die auf dich zu
fliegen oder nicht komm her dk der
fliegt direkt über so einen riesigen
lager see
er kommt er kommt bitte komm einfach ich
kann nichts dagegen tun
also ich hab ein entwickelt gelesen dass
die dinge unkontrolliert liegen was halt
bedeuten würde okay ich kann ihn nicht
irgendwie auf mich polen oder sowas
sondern ich muss einfach fragen das
machst du nicht bist du beschissen
was siehst du mich verarschen der basta
4 grad in kiel am rhein ein trend der
waadt okay ich habe noch ein plan ich
habe noch ein plan gibt es irgendwo blut
gibt es blut hier
ok ich brauchen blut sehen da vorne ist
einer da komme ich aber jetzt nicht hin
leute wir könnten es schaffen in dieser
folge zu fliegen
also ich hoffe du schaffst es weil ich
bin ich sie gebrochen mit dem projekt
gott muss da hin wo bist du mein
sonnenlicht geht davon gibt es hier ein
paar truhen die man abdecken kann
ich weiß nicht alte als gast du bist du
ich befürchte es weg nein ich hätte die
ganze zeit im blick und dann ist einfach
verschwunden
ich gucke ob ich irgendwo sein blut see
finde weil damit kann man ob sie die
anhalt erschaffen in der in der hölle
falls das nicht der fall ist dann sehe
ich schwarz für mich selbst leider
der vollblut da vorne ist eine kommt
kann ich muss jetzt echt riskieren so
kommt zack zack habe auch nicht mehr so
viel essen so bucket am start weiß essen
kriegen kannst bei 3 in der hölle
bei uns herrscht seit gestern zum schiff
das in melonen okay hallo hier ist
direktion so ein raum wo eigentlich
sachen diesmal noch kisten eigentlich
ich zumindest gesehen in manchen folgen
also fluten und stürmen bremer kisten
drin gefunden in solchen branchen aber
ein geht das ist ja vor und ist eine
kiste leute ich will zumindest eine
kiste öffnen wenn ich welche stress
mache ok lohnt sich überhaupt nicht so
ab weiter sich der wichtigen sache
widmen und zwar diesen verfluchten gas
zu finden oder einen verfluchten gast
offen wer will ich ja gar nicht
ich brenne schon wieder wegen dieser
ganz okay es haben wir uns blut geholt
und jetzt können wir nicht mehr machen
als einfach war grad in meiner eigenen
welt was passiert der gastes abgehauen
warum man alter also habe ich mich
gefühlt zu machen
so komm schon ich mache einfach mal
alles zu erzählen dass ich probieren
kann irgendwie diesen typen
wiederzufinden
auch es ist so stressig ich ja sagen
noch mal an
ja wir sind bei 16 minuten
aber das hat wehgetan hat sich bei
dieser zahl war man der bank vor meiner
nase davon ist so ein kauf
hellboy oder behalten
meine im endeffekt sind wir trotzdem gut
dabei im vergleich zu vielen anderen
sowas ja gut dass schon also erwartet
dank deiner rüstungs spende definitiv
gute kräfte ist auch direkt einen elfer
festung
ich will doch auch einfach nur ein gas
erreichen wo gott die viecher sind übel
die skelette kaum einer grotesken etwas
anders ist das ja gar nicht gemeint
haben die michalkow wollten war ich
nicht da habe ich dir den alter
sollte glücklich war so so kurz davor
fliegen zu können
bis ein ganzer kurz vor war also
wirklich hätten ihn töten müssen da der
mir geklappt fasste wieder fuß
einklappte 70 prozent locken die dame
gab tränen und eine heirat fliegen
können so verdammt schlimm oder bei
immerhin haben wir gerettet weil die
folge nicht ganz verschwendet aber die
zweite am anfang die ich damit verbracht
habe unnötigerweise was definitiv
verschwendeter braucht mir nicht nichts
vormachen abend ausklingen lassen
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen soll
frustriert ja komplett ich bin dabei
lasse übertreffen und ich weiß nicht ob
ich irgendwie so ein paar mops probieren
wollte gegen die pulle waffe geworden
kriegst du nicht hab mir schon die mox
enthält
aber die truppe hat so geringem anbieter
diese so stark
nein man jetzt bitte nicht sagt nicht
dass du bist ich kriege ich muss nur
aufpassen dass ich keinen song nicht
einschlagen
ok ich hab keinen soll mein auto geholt
und ich haben 13 also man sieht so gar
nicht okay alles klar
ich lebe ich lebe zwar leute auf sich
zeit die aber ich habe nicht genug
bekommen ich guck auf die zeit 19
minuten 39 kein herz kein gast in sicht
leute total abgefuckte das ding war vor
meiner nase hätte einmal den bogen
spannen müssen den typen abgeschossen
und ich hätte das zeug einfach nur
höchst wahrscheinlich bekommen der ist
einfach die sport- oder so man
ich glaube dass mal wieder zurück in
richtung portal aber die folge für heute
musste ich schon mal beenden auf jeden
fall was in der nächsten folge irgendwie
den dungeon wir ein bisschen unter die
lupe nehmen und dort an halt irgendwie
keine ahnung was was weiß ich überhaupt
was ich machen soll auf den dungeon und
die lupe nehmen und hier einfach warten
das ist wieder ein gast und ich weiß es
nicht leute keine ahnung dass mein
kommentar den staffellauf
macht's gut